il ya quelques semaines dans cette
émission jean pierre bernès est venu
donner sa version de la sphère au mba ce
soir la parole est à l'accusation
voici jacques glassmann et son avocat
eric dupond moretti
tout et tout est résumé dès le départ
c'est à dire que maintenant quand
jacques glassmann arrive dans un dans
une émission de télévision comme sur un
stade
il est hué donc c'est pas pour ça que tu
es venu avec toi avec ton avocat
non non pas du tout alors on va
commencer par un bref rappel des faits
ensuite on va voir ce qui s'est passé
depuis un an depuis la sphère au mba et
puis on discutera de ton avenir alors au
niveau du rappel des faits en ce qui te
concerne deux questions restent en
suspens la première c est ce que même
pendant un très court laps de temps
tu as été complice de la magouille
j'ai jamais été complices comme j'ai dit
gg relater les faits j'ai relaté tout ce
qui s'était passé et puis je les dis à
mes dirigeants et à la presse c'est tout
donc ça veut dire que même si tu as
donné l'impression à robert et
burruchaga pendant un moment d'être
complice et une habileté de ta part j'ai
pas arrêté de leur dire qu'il fallait
pas accepté je crois que l'on leur
conscience moi j'ai la mienne ils ont
pris une décision j'en ai pris une autre
je crois que c'est chacun fait un choix
je n'y avait pas de chef de bande
c'était pas moi de dicter leur conduite
et je crois que j'ai fait le bon choix
ils ont fait le mauvais choix
la deuxième question qui se pose est
celle à la défense de bernès défense qui
là qu'il a tenus ici c'est lui dit est
ce que ces trois gars enfin est-ce que
la semaine est sûr que c'était moi qui
parlais au téléphone
bon avec la discussion qui a eu après
avec jorge burruchaga c'est bon c'est ça
qui m'a qui m'a indiqué que ça pouvait
être que lui s'il y avait que lui qui
pouvait être au courant de 2,2 ce qu'ils
ont dit et puis on sent quand tu as
entendu
burruchaga discuter de maradona avec le
correspondant téléphonique
tu as eu la certitude qu'il s'agissait
de bernès je pensais que c'était lui est
bon même maintenant il ya une chose qui
revient bon j'ai eu la chance de le
rencontrer pendant les confrontations
bon il ya une intonation de voix qui
était exactement la même alors
finalement donc ce qu'on peut dire
depuis depuis un an c'est que toi qui
aurait dû devenir un héros parce que tu
avait dénoncé la corruption pour
pratiquement tout le monde puis devenu
une balance un traître comment tu
analyses cette situation aujourd'hui
ici les gens prennent un malin plaisir à
me us et c'est leur problème je crois
que c'est c'est triste je crois qu'il
faudrait regarder objectivement ce qui
s'est passé et prendre tous les frais
c'est tout je demande pas qui m'a clame
mais c'est vrai de se faire huer c'est
pas c'est pas marrant il a brisé la loi
du milieu qui a brisé l'omerta c'est ça
contre proches final je pouvais pas
laisser passer ça je crois que avec mes
idées mes convictions et est ce que je
suis je pouvais pas laisser passer ça
dès le départ tu as reçu des coups de
fil anonymes les menaces de mort et des
menaces de mort marc lettre par lettre
ou et surtout par lettre anonyme bien
sûr bien sûr et de guy
c'est pas mieux et tutu a déclaré tu dis
quand on voit bernès avait clamé au
stade vélodrome qui fait le tour du
stade vélodrome avec tout le monde qui
l'applaudît c'est le monde à l'envers ça
t'as fait quoi quand tu as vu ça à la
télévision surtout bon qui qui crierait
bon j'ai pas craquer cos pour moi ça
veut tout dire quoi il dit pas je suis
pas coupable il dit j'ai pas craquer
donc alors toi maintenant chaque fois
qui va sur un terrain de foot il ya des
banderoles et les quolibets
on te crie glassman téléphone
glassman la honte de l'aspan balance
c'est d'être infernale jouer dans ces
conditions
je crois que ça a été ça a été dur au
début c'est vrai que je m'y attendais
pas tellement mais bon
au fil de l'année je crois que je me
suis mis une petite une petite carapace
et puis j'ai réussi à surmonter ça je
crois que c'est pas les gens qui vont me
faire abandonner mais très choquée que
de constater finalement qu'on fait
passer le fanatisme avant les valeurs
quoi tu n'en doutez pas un peu avant non
je m'en doutais pas dans ce vrai je
pensais qu'ils allaient avoir des
jambons ses droits dès des fanatiques
des supporters de marseille tout ça je
les comprends parce que peut-être
quelque part ils comprennent pas mais
bon moi je pense que de là à m'insulter
tout ça c'est quand même mais il a
toujours été un peu comme ça c'est vrai
qu'à strasbourg tu t'étais rebeller
contre à un entraîneur qui a insulté les
joueurs déjà assez vrai parce que il
insultait des jeunes joueurs qui étaient
là pour apprendre le métier donc c'était
je crois que c'était pas une bonne
solution mais c'est pareil j'aime pas
l'étiquette de rebelles je suis pas un
rebelle je suis chez un mec tout à fait
normal mais quand il ya des choses qui
vont pas et si je pense que j'ai raison
je crois que je donne mon opinion c'est
tout à fait normal
côté sur un stade tu as peur de recevoir
autre chose que des que des insultes de
recevoir des projectiles par exemple
dans le genre j'en ai déjà vu on m'a
jeté des pièces et puis des faux billets
c'est c'est toute l'intelligence quoi
mais bon je vous dis je veux pas juger
les gens et puis c'est comme ça c'est
tout ça s'est fait un petit peu drogués
je les prends pas
et des fois qu'ils sont encore pire tu
peux même pas jouer c'est ce qui s'est
passé à nice
qu'est ce qui s'est passé exactement ben
là je crois que c'est là où ça m'a fait
le plus mal je crois que bon je m'étais
préparé pendant pratiquement trois
semaines c'était le premier match de la
saison est bon m'avertit pratiquement
trois heures avant de partir et je crois
que là alors qu'on m'avait dit que
j'allais jouer qui avait qui allait
avoir des de la suite de la sécurité à
nice et homme-là on me l'a dit trois
heures avant le match ça a été ça a été
terrible
donc quand tu as découvert que les
dirigeants du club avaient cédé au
chantage
tu t'es mis à pleurer sa ré c'est vrai
c'est vrai que j'ai pleuré et samassa
m'a vraiment dégoûté moi je voulais pas
céder au chantage bon maintenant mes
dirigeants ont pris leurs
responsabilités
c'est dommage puisqu'on voit que sur
tous les autres stades ça a été la même
chose donc j'aurais pu très bien pu
jouer ce match il ya qu à marseille que
tu pourras jamais jouer quoi
bah je sais pas j'en sais rien on verra
tirer bat mois ci si sportivement je
suis prêt à jouer
je suis prêt à jouer sur tous les stades
de france j'ai pas que toi tu rentrerait
au stade vélodrome a bien sûr rentrer
savoir alors va maintenant passer at on
à ton avenir ton contrat avec
valenciennes se termine à la fin du mois
de juin
donc à partir de la fin du mois de juin
étaient au chômage tu as une idée quel
club va embaucher l'année prochaine
c'est pas ça me paraît difficile c'est
vrai que en réfléchissant un petit peu
vu vu ce que les dirigeants du football
français ont montré pour l'instant au
niveau de la solidarité je crois que les
gens quand même sanctionné durement
bernès qui est
radié à vie tapie et et l'om qui a
rétrogradé en seconde division quand
même c'est vrai mais je crois que ça va
être difficile pour moi de trouver un
club dans la mesure où est ce qu un
président et un entraîneur de club si
sportivement ils ont envie que je joue
dans leurs équipes vont prendre le
risque justement de de faire subir à
leurs équipes à travers moi
des sifflets et puis de bon des
problèmes qu'ils ont pensé ils vont pas
engager un joueur qui s'il fait cinq
minutes club dorothée ils sont habitués
aussi protéger
alors oui tu as dit à valeur égale entre
un autre joueur et moi on voit là
toujours l'autre surnom je pense que fo
faudra le demander au président je ne
sais pas tu a flingué ta carrière un peu
quand même
bah sûrement oui sûrement mais c'est pas
grave
au moment où tu as décidé de te raconter
ce dont tu avais été témoin at&t
dirigeants tu savais que tu flinguer ta
carrière j'en sais rien je sais pas que
je savais pas que les gens allaient
réagir de la sorte mais bon je savais
très bien que que les gens ont peur je
sais pas pourquoi ils ont peur de parler
on arrête je crois qu'on a toujours peur
de la vérité c'est pour moi c'est triste
pour moi c'est triste si tu l'avais su
tu aurais parlé quand même je regrette
parce que ce que j'ai fait et je ça se
reproduise je le referais je n'ai aucun
regret est-ce que tu risque d'arrêter le
foot mais je crois que si si dans un
voire deux mois j'ai pas de club je
crois que je vais être obligé d'arrêter
le foot ou bon de partir à l'étranger je
ne sais pas au canada par exemple bas au
canada où n'importe où là où on voudra
de moi si tu restes en france n'a pas
peur un jour parce que tu as l'air assez
solide quand même mais deux à force
d'être sifflé d'être hué comme ça de
complètement disjoncté sur un stade
je crois que j'en ai eu l'occasion
souvent scanner surtout que ça pas très
bien marché au niveau sportif avec
valenciennes
mais je crois que je
je me suis bien maîtrisée pour l'instant
et puis j'espère que dans l'avenir ça va
se passer de la même façon et quand il
joue il est avec toi et oui maintenant
qu'un avocat je coupe les citrons même
pas finalement conclusion tu as
découvert que dénoncer une magouille
dans la france d'aujourd'hui c'était
plus grave que de la faire moi je dis
qu'on marche sur la tête
parce que comme vous le dit très
justement la dénonciation de la
magouille devient plus grave que la
magouille
je voudrais porter un petit correctif
thierry est ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure c'est pas trois personnes qui
ont tendu berner ses quatre et parmi les
quatre personnes y avait deux lits qui
appartient à l'équipe de l'olympique de
marseille
et puis je veux dire aussi à tous ceux
qui accusaient de la semaine d'être une
balance que c'est jamais que la
troisième fois que l'olympique de
marseille se retrouve dans cette
situation car les instances du football
ont eu à connaître à deux reprises de
magouilles de cette nature et à deux
reprises les agissements des dirigeants
de l'olympique de marseille ont été
fustigés pointe à la ligne résultat des
courses il est une balance téléphone
tout ce que l'on peut entendre et
l'autre se fait acclamer par vingt mille
spectateurs en tournant autour du stade
vélodrome des joueurs de marseille qui
non content le regardais pas moi je pas
le procureur moi je dis des conneries
c'est tout écoute on va faire ce que
peut-être tu espérais qu on qu'on fasse
de temps en temps comme paix sur un
terrain d'entente tout le monde qui
hurle on va te dématérialisée et vous
aussi
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu